[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
this is kind donations as far as I know
this is the first animal cross the prop
is the first animal crossing horror game
I've ever played
also I've never played Animal Crossing
I've seen it though good-evening link
welcome to the blank Museum how may I be
of service
mega donation SS fossils yes yes yes yes
foss foss foss SS boss
tell me about Vic tell me about this who
I must say I'm intrigued to see what
you'll bring me next how about what are
they are you sure if there's anything
you want to know you have but to ask
is there anything else I could help you
with uh yes yes yes my fossils alas you
have on no unknown fossils for me to
inspect not to worry you can bring me as
fossil any old time woohoo a bit of
fossil humor there is there anything
else I'm gonna with make a donation
marvelous what would you like to donate
Oh
what what what is what is what wretched
things my sincerest thanks for your
donations rest assured they they will
get the best of care here please enjoy
the rest of your visit is it is it bugs
I know he doesn't like bugs
I want a me play Oh Oh press shift of
you how many bugs remain what Oh sounds
like a bugger
Oh maybe after what what's down there
blathers what's down there boy he blew
some fresh air would be rather nice but
work comes first my little town slamming
the woods dark thought I would have all
what wah wah wah wah wah wah ha ha ah ha
ha well some birds prey on bugs the
praying mantis is not the prey it is the
predator
if hungry enough that they will target
more than just insects but fully grown
birds they wait perfectly still until
their prey comes close please no that
may strike I see interesting fascinating
ok good mmm ok good um I want to know
how I entered the Shadow Realm the old
birds in a vice grip with powerful
raptorial legs as they punctured their
catches skulls and eat them alive
great mantis March 17th 1985 donated by
blathers thank you Oh dad hi
let's get on with it one I just what
happened we didn't find any bugs
I just died what happened oh oh
[Music]
hello hi can I have you oh my oh okay
okay
yeah I'm a dead bird Oh hoot on my grave
release the butterflies sure the
butterflies fall out of your hands they
seem to have trouble staying on the tree
oh oh okay okay well made do I need to
glue them onto the tree so what you're
telling me I need to do thank you for
all your kind donations
oh you're welcome you know how I love to
donate warning please not touch or budge
the cases the insects in this exhibit
have been carefully organized so that
each is at comfortable distance from
their more predatorial kin okay the pill
bug or roly poly is famous for their
defensive mechanism of rolling up into a
ball in addition they require moist
environments to live which is why they
prefer being beside a bug caught from or
around bodies of water such as for
instance the Worf roach or the humble
hermit crab their natural predators
include centipedes ants spiders and
early in life their own kind there are
over 12,000 different species of ants
worldwide they're one of the strongest
species recorded in relation to their
diminutive size their natural predators
include beetles spiders centipedes and
snails
oh how ow we only ask you for your
donations to add to our display case is
empty oh I see it's a puzzle Worf Roche
understood
I see snail hermit crab
centipede uh so pillbug prefer being
beside bugs Wharf roach hermit crab
centipedes ants and spiders are the
enemy
so Edel okay that's not a problem
Worf roach that's not a problem snail
that's okay
hermit crab that's fine centipede that's
no good that's no bueno it were first I
would might put it down there beetles
spiders centipedes and snails okay so
this can't be anywhere near snails
right ants camping near snails or
centipedes so centipedes are no beetles
are here centipedes are over here so I
guess right here for the here for the
pill bug you here for the ant it's that
good
did I do good I think I did good oh I
didn't do good oh no oh no oh I didn't
do good oh I did bad oh I did bad oh I
did oh I did so bad oh no oh I did bad
let's try that again okay I'm sorry
oh yeah take the answer I thought okay
so hermit crab and centipedes so the ant
can't be by the centipede okay wait what
else was and not good for all beetles
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay so this has got to be pill bug and
this has to be ant right that's got to
be right that's got to be good that's so
good so good so good yes oh what
happened oh oh no oh no no oh that's not
good oh hey oh no oh no oh no oh no
cuckoo cuckoo
okay tarantula what okay so um so what
about that I don't know the layout of
this bow that sake for all your kind
donate name is covered in something
sticky and read it the boy yeah okay
let's do that
how foul chicken joke
these are chickens these are chicken is
old here your butterflies get stuck to a
tree
take that butterfly you gently adhere
the butterflies to the tree I'm sure
they'll love that Gary they aren't
moving which I guess was the objective
I'm glad I am happy about that
all right I've got a ladybug good good
oh no not this what are you so worried
about I mean everything that's going on
is absolutely horrible so yeah you
should absolutely be worried it's not
that bad Oh some watering can
okay what do I do with the watering can
what is a nice I need to fill it with
water of course
apart from more aquatic inclined insects
fill up your water
can yes absolutely filled up my watering
watering there's it that should be
enough yeah sure whatever you say I'm
sure it'll be enough do I need to water
the roses over here there was a room
over here with roses and another herbs
intros for wallah what add plants yes
sure ladybug crawls out of your pocket
it Nestle's between the tulip bloods
buds and flutters it wings well that's
nice the ladybug is grazing between the
tulip books well that's nice that's
really nice oh did they all have options
for nice things well that was just
ghastly hopefully that'll be the last
bulk of them for some time perhaps I'll
call it early tonight oh yeah yep yep
yeah I just take my chicken butt back
the bird bb-dub oh no not this way this
is down here is this worth maybe maybe
after whoo
did I lock the doors on my way in where
the Dickens did I put my Dickens I
believe I left a spare key in the back
in the back you say maybe have you have
to have in the back in the is this way
to the back who don't have this way this
way I don't know what the the back is
[Music]
that can't be good
whoo how you doing good to see you who
do you are you gonna run gonna run gonna
run gonna run no thing you know that you
are thought there was a no oh that no
boy butterflies in my dreams butterflies
wow the next nine oh good there's more
I really should come to this island more
often I haven't thought about it much
before it's been a dreadfully long time
since we've gone stargazing wouldn't you
say I'm glad we get to do this again and
on such a beautiful night at that mm-hmm
oh dear I know that look another rough
night was it well I suppose I couldn't
have come at a better time I know your
work can be difficult for you but I just
want you to remember one thing for me
all right we spend so much time apart
now so I never get to chance to say but
no matter how hard you try no matter how
far apart we are no matter what is
nobody else I'd rather have as my
brother now please enough browsing I
think I just saw a shooting star there
see
oh that's nice that's lovely
that's lovely I thought that was gonna
be a horrible ending I thought it was
gonna no matter how far away you are
you could never forgive yourself of
getting up praying mantises that killed
day or something like that all right
that was good I like that a lot
it's been a while since I played like an
RPG Maker horror game like a legit one
and that was a pretty legit one I like
that that was good stuff or if there's
been any more made in the recent times I
know there's been like more gmod horror
maps sonic go back to those is because I
know there's probably tons that I
haven't had a chance to play so anyway
that's pretty good next one
ooh the sensitivity so high this is my
secret little diary whoa is that is that
my pooping hole oh my god it's my
pooping hole isn't it oh that's my poop
oh no that's not a good clock can you
help me who's speaking
I lost my diary I don't know where it is
it's really stressful I didn't intend
for anyone to you know read it yeah okay
I have some bad thoughts but that's why
they go into my diary it's really like
this if it's not in me how can it be in
me if you find it please don't read it
just burn it maybe you want to sleep now
I don't know who's talking about I'm
going to sleep here I go my eyes are
heavy I'm awake hello I don't know
what's happened
what a curlicue swings wrong Oh Oh
spaghetti I hold that spaghetti wool why
is there a two year old practicing piano
over here
well I if your objective was to make me
confused color may confuse where's this
diary I've heard so much about heard
it's a good read this is more poop am I
about to find poop that's not poop I
don't know what does everyone please
collectively delete that from your
memories no thank you no thank you I'm
just wandering off into the nothingness
I feel like I'm just wandering off into
the nothingness hey shadow or something
oh I can go through it fascinating Lexi
and put it on jump-scare just keep
everyone on their toes but don't tell
them when it's gonna happen keep it real
seeker like yeah you never know when
it's coming
now that I've told Lexi to do it you
know it's on the way that would have
been a good opportunity for it but he
didn't do it yet maybe maybe he did
maybe he didn't maybe you don't know
maybe you never know when it's gonna
come could be now could be then could be
never maybe he's not gonna listen to me
maybe he's gonna choose this moment to
rebell
ah ah oh hi oh dear play Oh your player
I love you Oh
saranghae will you ever read these words
I don't know who cares I love you so
much I don't know what I'd do without
you
it breaks my heart that we are not
together 24/7 when I wake up in the
morning I want you to be by my side when
you smile I see your smile when you cry
I see your tears and I kiss your smile I
kiss your tears
maybe I'll kiss your ears woohoo
I wish I could just tell you straight I
love you forever I just can't
that's too straight here's a poem I
wrote today it's for you a dove reaches
out a CAW finds its Cove a lampshade
wears its post a candy tightrope seals
its fate a deal is broken a heart is
broken two people just don't get it but
it's the same it's just like you need
something to love even the most hentai
Dougan po speaks in poetry don't come
any closer
what was that you what were you thinking
what was I telling you please back away
please back right now back away now of
the nether yeah I thought it was a
painting getting closer
I don't need you reading in my diary is
for me haha I'll go this way
well means I love memes diary of memes
are verses of Allah whoa oh hey okay see
around Oh hate hate hate hate hate hate
hate hate hate hate hate all right an
Iron Maiden okay I'm gonna now boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy here we go
am i dead wixi did you do this I'm scare
yet oh it's my toy oh it's my clock oh
it's my poop oh oh hi oh oh my god I'm
sorry I'm so sorry I don't know why I'm
doing this I don't want to hurt you
please forgive me please take me back
I'll never hurt you again my brain it's
just missing screws gives me my mischief
I have these little acting you know
because I am like this I just I can't be
with people I can't be in society I
can't have friends it's impossible to
not sin that's by design
can you forgive me if you see my diary
just forget about it it's stupid I have
nothing to say just miserable bad
thoughts
there's nicer things to read like the
Bible hey wait are you sleeping I don't
know am i slipping oh no what a sleep
who wanna be awake oh I'm back and I'm
tiny Oh flowers
sure seems like a breadcrumb trail of
flowers mm-hmm oh wow oh my oh my oh my
dear player still I can't stop thinking
about you I wonder if you can feel it
are you even so clueless you must have
no idea but thinking about you makes me
feel so crazy but I don't know what to
do about it I'll never show you this
that's too real how could I
you'll never accept me today I think so
much about us about Jesus about my
misfits those revenge people taking on
me but you know I just figured it out
I'd realized it if now we are all in the
same sense the Lamb of sacrifice is my
fate God wants me to be the photographer
ice love is like debts but it's not like
money your numbers in a bank account
God's love is endless and selfless just
imagine all humans also can love
endlessly and selflessly yet the nasties
so affect us and evils are still around
us so the situation is like that someone
gives endless love to their lover but
the lava keeps hurting their heart using
the love to play gambling and using it
up the person who is loving this little
nest you won't get depression but the
love regardless love beyond all loves
never depleted that scares people
feeling like losing all the things in
the world once they get through it
there's the happiness there and they
will know that where there's nothing but
void once a person gives love to the
idols there's love dead created
but oh not this again oh please I don't
want it up you see I wasn't reading your
diet oh here we go
it was deep why why just why can you
tell me why really can you have any
thinking twice my privacy this isn't
some casual reading it's not a [ __ ]
time line wake up I don't have time for
this all right cool your little sneaky
snooping you little worm you little baby
I'll show you sin I'll kill you sir ah
God every time didn't you hear me that
my me did I ever say you who's that I
don't know about you you're nothing just
quit your little game causing me grief
and sorrow forget about me go play some
other game
dig a hole whatever just forget about me
I'm happy being without you I'm happy
without you in my life oh hi
great oh my pooping hole oh wow ah okay
oh I can hey can you hear me who made
this mess was its
are you ready to go we're leaving you
want to stay here who else going to take
you what do you think you could manage
on your own that's cute
sorry I mean look it's time to go you
talk about it later
what are we talking about what are we
talking about what are we talking about
talking about what are you talking about
oh you bastard you're stealing my height
oh well it's oddly peaceful now little
strange oh I didn't mean those words
don't you get it I'm really just like
this I'm not sick you know how people
are like of that person did these bad
things they are mentally ill whatever
laundry list of labels
I think that's so sad to say this I'm
not broken I'm not ill I can't change
this it's not going away if you love me
you won't judge me for my wiring one day
I want to kiss your heart another day I
want to break your bones I think both of
those would end in the death of the
person that's balanced why hide from
emotions bad emotions I want it all I
don't want to pretend I can only see
blue and greens why do that I don't know
what you want to do about it we should
just need ice cream not talk so much
take care of our bellies and love each
other you know what there's a poem for
you it's good I poem on the black screen
I cry to them how it's a mellow and -
you destroy my candy banks harmlessly i
crawl through your ranks remember when
we used to steal love gems I don't know
how I'm gonna get through this well you
by my side wherever you are I don't know
have like this in the way ok ok goodbye
goodbye I have no idea not one peep not
one boob I've got no oh alright finally
found a place to practice the slopes
were so crowded and everyone was going
so fast this looks like a path I can
just stay out of everyone's way
[Music]
Oh
oh it's like deal whoa it's the old ski
game
[Applause]
[Music]
what's the bug sure this is the area she
was last seen what doctors happened
let's take a look at this report again
ahem
Miriam Steele 24 reported missing since
this morning all right Miriam I'll find
you don't worry oh no no oh no oh no no
no no no no no what is this a backpack
there's a nametag on the side just as I
thought it's miss steeles what happened
to you out here
I don't want to know no runaway sheriff
sheriff run away run away run away
sheriff run away Oh run away sheriff
sheriff you need to run Ski freak oh no
you need to run Sheriff don't go in the
big old dildo hole Oh No why am I so
scared of it Emma's not looking [ __ ] of
a game don't do it hi Birds - who picks
last Birds right need to call the mayor
phone is on the desk Miriam she wasn't
right couldn't get a word out of her
hopefully after some rest in a warm
hospital bed the doc can get her talking
poor girl she was alive what a [ __ ] she
was loud oh I'm sure from another day on
the job that big ol handlebar mustache
how am i able to tell that this guy has
a freakin Captain Crunch hat a handlebar
mustache and two big-ass blue kovat
night team clothes mayor it's Jim yeah
she's at the hospital now what do you
mean keep it on the low I know good and
well it's tourist season but calling in
a professional what do you wanna know
these man like I do look I don't know
what's going on but this girl's the only
one who's gone missing is showing up
again you want me to lay low forget the
election
up yours Gerald God it was all alright a
woman that's still missing
apparently she killed her husband and
daughter while they were all eating
dinner stabbed the girl in the back and
slit the husband's rope what's the world
coming to these days a grandfather went
crazy last year
and tried to murder his wife and
grandchildren he's at the loony bin now
claim he was possessed don't believe in
all that one who a vigilante at large in
the big city heard she took out a whole
gang after the kidnapped her son don't
know what the city folk called justice
but she's a hero in my book empty empty
don't even know why I have these in the
first place empty alright weird alright
it's a cold one today I love I miss
games add descriptions over every single
thing like so many interactable alright
oh ski freak presto I haven't even
started the game what are you talking
about Oh what the fair is this Johnny
likes rad things you know it isn't rad
missing sister oh my god his bug he was
trying to fly right in my eye
Johnny travels to the glacier Peaks in
search of her and he won't let anything
not even a secretive community deter his
mission
Greta a former world champion is
hell-bent on proving that job what the
hell happened
Klaus once respected doctor has been on
the hunt for a mountain creature for
decades after being attacked and
paralyzed by one now he is fuelled by
the drive to bring the light to the
existence of these monsters let's go
Johnny
oh this mount is huge I have to find my
sister in some way I should also hang up
some flyers is worth chef is this a full
last game what you were looking for your
sister the people in this community like
just about everyone who's gone missing
lasted west of the mountain I'd go
looking down Russell trail the start is
just outside you can't miss it don't
trust anybody and don't make loud noises
out there good luck okay Oh
this is a full ass game the hell there's
at least 30 missing people I don't think
I'll get any answers up here it's an
article headline local resident and
former doctor convinced on the existence
of the rest is too faded out to read if
you know it's best for you you'd leave
this mound while you still can
not gonna listen me your funeral to stay
out of my way okay these American swine
think they can scalp me out of this
competition that there are stupid as
they look no offense
hope you find your sister you must leave
me now focusing on being the best policy
she can live and doing Merman
I mean I'll provide your sister I'm sure
she's still alive this brush loves this
digitally thought alright okay
this trail she went missing shoe blue
alright here we go
shipping it will we will be do but it
will be do be will be do be will be will
be do badoo badoo will be will be do be
do will you do
problem detected I've detected some
problems here who might be surprised
problems everybody there seem to be some
problems
radical oh my god
the freak the freak what the Frick is
this the race starts in half an hour I
need to find my equipment ah you need to
find your grave oh my grandma would
always head over to carry you're gonna
die I'll buy equipment I'll definitely
need these just my clothes and malls
perhaps
where's my gun doesn't work in this
filthy cabin oh wow
what what what what the zoom on that
picture
and then the grandma picture now merge
them and overlay them together okay good
I found the scuse Oh beautiful dnf1
please table is all set for my victory
tonight what a sad life is so sad all
right bye
bye grandma bye grandpa assirram
what what was that on the window top
right window there was something up
there
this letter looks old there's a bit hard
to read I told them I told them that we
have angered these bums something is
stirring awakening I can hear it at
night over the wind you can hear it
morning angry it doesn't want us here I
fear that if we do not leave we will
soon discover why no one lives out here
Oh
Oh No Oh
[Music]
no no don't do credit go home credit
credit go home credit go home
credit go home Greta go home
Greta go home Greta go home brother go
home a ripped up shirt where could this
have come from go home Brad a go home
still warm
someone wants to bend here not long if
this is a pile of [ __ ] am I to stick my
hand in a pile of poop
still warm where are they now a tent
hello no answer I don't have a good
feeling about this granite go home clink
Clank clink Clank Clank Clank Clank
clink Clank clink Brad I go home the
starting line is just a bad I need to
focus
no am i letting Hans rub his rub
anything in my face oh yeah
eat my dust dillweeds I don't want to
eat your dust
oh my god the woods like the cursor cut
I took Jorgen very brutally profusely
bleeding profusely so much blood I got
so much blood taking complete to die
from blood loss oh my god I'm good oh
god please oh did I make it
oh that's not good oh that's not good
the thumping and the foo Ming ain't good
it's what you call not good and not good
o'clock hey where'd my Oh be quiet what
I was trying to be quiet I was trying to
talk to the person I didn't think that
it was a thing Oh No Oh Brenda go go go
okay we're all good so good got my back
now and they grew back I am home totally
fine I am so good I am good I love my
life and not dying to a horrible
monstrosity that is chasing me
okay we're all good so good I don't know
where I'm going at an old
[Music]
okay Klaus Klaus said he was paralyzed
Stephen has now returned for a few hours
and it is getting dark soon
something is wrong I have to get out of
bed clothes slow for Klaus my old pickup
truck linea wish I could ride her again
I've never felt so bad about Oh Oh No
good lord Rex you were a good boy no no
Steven it can't be his head has been
ripped apart of us get to my ski car Oh
God Rex no why am i more worried about
Rex than Steven ah my priorities damn
them to hell
okay oh it's lovely
wait Klaus
wait Klaus Klaus Oh what the hell is
that about my eye what kind of net
launcher was that my freaking eye oh my
god what is this what is this what is
this what is this what is this I don't
know this is absurd I don't know why why
[Music]
little Dada
it's freaking Santa Claus I didn't even
think about a frickin Santa Claus
oh oh oh it's the dude it's the dude
who's like just get out of my way oh
yeah yes yes you can't get me so good so
good so you want to get some body found
on Russel trail the body of a glacier
Peaks visitor Johnny Steele was found by
locals in the early morning hours
it appears being unfamiliar with the
area the 28 year old become lost and
succumbed to extreme temperatures the
corpse is found to have vast external
injuries but is being chalked up to
wildlife
strangely enough Steele sister Miriam
Steele had gone missing last week and
still has not been found
authorities asked for respect towards
the victims of the investigation the
ordeal of seeing her fellow competitors
slaughtered nearly losing her own life
grant ahead to undergo intense therapy
to be able to return to the mountains
and resume skiing however due to her
strong spirit Greta is chosen and not
let the terrible events control her life
she no longer competes professionally
but she has embraced her love of the
sport and opened up her own ski school
while she will never return to Glacier
Peaks Greta can't help but look over her
shoulders some days the minut Claus was
able to check himself out of the
hospital he immediately resumed all his
research into the mountain creatures it
has seemed that the creature if there
were more than one have migrated away
from the area clause followed suit and
is now conducting his research in the
Alps where he hopes he can catch one
alive this daring task is one that Claus
plans to continue for the rest of his
life not that he has much left
damn the monster has been killed in
Glacier Peaks is now safe the hunter
returns to his life of mystery and it
seems that authorities have put the
clamp on any publication or
investigations of what transpired on
that mountain many questions remain as
to what exactly was terrorizing the town
however while there is a new sense of
ease in the area if you listen closely
at night you can hear something brewing
in the darkness of the pines and within
the unexplored ridges of the mountain I
am
yeah I am stunned yeah I am stunned that
was amazing for a game that literally
looked slugging in the stas game which
it was emulating that was really good
made by the same people that made power
drill master and stuff like that there's
a lot of that that was great
lee seon did you do that scum that
jump-scare the scum scare the scum scum
scared this is the jump scare with the
skunk scare him with a skunk
good job thank you all right so that was
three scary games hope you enjoyed that
I know I did did you get spooked did you
maybe you haven't yet maybe is still
coming yeah I'll just leave it at that
so thank you if you want to check out
more scary games that I've played
they're linked in the description or in
the suggested videos if you dare leave a
like if you got spooked subscribe for
more thank you and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]